[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor as I prefer to think of it dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give you
to be this advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John did you know that I broke
my hand during high school rollerblading
but but you wouldn't think I'd be so
surprised about it why is that I don't
know it's just really hard to grasp oh
my god I was terrible that feels like
when you wrote yourself not one that you
got from a list of dad jokes is a
combination I was inspired by a joke I
saw elsewhere I'm I didn't laugh but I
did make a slightly derisively sound so
we'll put that on the list of good ones
then no was achieved Hank do you want to
know some good news this week I always
do the 8th episode Hulu adaptation of
Looking for Alaska has cast its lead
actors Charlie Plummer and Christine
frozen and they're both such lovely
lovely people I talked to them both on
the phone and they could not have been
nicer and I'm just
it's been a long 13 years but I am so so
grateful that that these young people
are going to be part of the looking for
the story I'm really psyched well I
guess my book is out now so I guess
we'll see it see it on coming to the big
or small screen sometime in the mid
2030s yeah as if they'll be humans then
that's great news John thanks for the
bringing it back down okay I did break
my hand while rollerblading in high
school though yeah I know I know if you
want to talk about a sport that has not
aged well yeah it's kind of
disappointing I wish that I saw more
rollerblading Montana is particularly a
bad place to rollerblade one because
it's lots of hills and two because we're
really bad at infrastructure right
there's not a ton of like real smooth
side
walks no no all the sidewalks are over a
hundred years old and the freeze-thaw
cycles do wreak havoc on anything solid
that's that's that's that's the kind of
high-quality informational content if
you'll come to do do you want to know
what it's like to rollerblade in
Missoula Montana we've got information
for you hey do you want to hear about a
sport that last existed before you were
born
people still rollerblade you're gonna
alienate all our rollerblade listeners
oh I assume this is all for Nick not for
not for the pod all right Hank let's
answer some questions from our listeners
that sounds like not a terrible idea
this first question comes from Morgan
who asks dear Hank and John does milk
expire when it's inside a cow pumpkins
and penguins Oregon Oh Morgan I think
that you might have been misinformed
about the way that milking works milk if
women would expire when it's inside of a
cow I guess but the cow would expire
first well in the in and of in the way
that like that like a cat like a that
inside of a dead cow the milk would
expire is that what you're saying
because that is true I'm saying that if
a cow died with milk inside of it that
milk would not be permanently drinkable
yeah that sounds right you know why
Morgan you know why Morgan because
nothing lasts forever not even cold
November rain not even the human species
not even milk not even milk inside of a
cow yeah Hank do you ever pause to
consider how incredibly weird it is that
adult humans drink the milk of a
different mammal I don't think it's that
weird John I don't think it's that weird
well there is no other species that
drinks the milk of a different animal
into adults another species that does
any of this stuff we do oh I can name a
number of other species that whisper
I've recently reviewed it on the
anthropocene reviewed there's a monkey
that whispers raccoons whisper oh that's
lovely but John there are there are
butterflies that drink the tears of a
animals like weed it's there's always
somebody that does something and and
lots of vampiric species that drink
blood including humans humans drink the
blood of animals hmm or or eat it if we
mix it into harder stuff personally I
only I only try to do that in an
emergency but I know I know there's a
lot of different ways to be a person
yeah absolutely yeah I do
I do I think that if you look at
anything from from the wide lens it's
like oh that's very straight I find it
very strange that humans come out of
other humans and that every human did
that I think that that's weird but it's
very normal it's like the weirdest
matroyshka doll possible like you open
up one matroyshka doll and inside of it
is a matroyshka doll that was born from
the larger matroyshka doll yeah I don't
really thought of it in that way but
here we are all all inside of our
nesting doll of the human species going
all the way back to like ultimately like
single-celled organisms so it's pretty
weird John it's pretty weird what are we
talking about Hank does milk expire when
it's inside a cow no no no no I'm not
really an expert on this but I'm pretty
sure now I'm gonna lean toward no but I
do know that with contemporary dairy
farming practices it can be quite bad
for a cow not to milk them yes and also
like I think that we sometimes think
about milk as like a thing that like it
gets like it fills up the sack and then
it just sits there
it doesn't just sit there it actually
like it's continually replenished by
like new fluids coming in and coming out
of the of the milk so it's it's like
almost always fresh because it's always
being refresh and inside the cow or
whatever mammal great I think we've
covered it this next question comes from
Stephanie who writes Dear John and Hank
I work in an office with a lot of other
people and one of the hazards of my job
is that those people have babies I do
not have a baby and I have not spent a
lot of time around babies and I have not
spent a lot of time around people who
spend time around babies I know that
when people have children they like to
talk about them and it's nice to hear
how happy
get when people do talk about their kids
but because of my extremely limited
knowledge of babies I never have any
idea what questions to ask like is it
weird to ask if a five month old has
teeth can they eat a chicken nugget yet
[Laughter]
wait wait wait I need to know has it had
a chicken nugget I can go get a chicken
nugget can I be its first chicken nugget
I can't imagine being a human on earth
without having a chicken nugget and that
baby is one of those imagine that you're
telling a nice anecdote about your five
month-old baby and Stephanie says oh
that's a great story
hey as your kid had a chicken nugget yet
and you're like no I mean I know they're
not allowed to eat solid food and also
no I mean uh chicken nuggets are so good
though are not his first fish sticks
last night can they talk when they're
five months old that's another one of
Stephanies questions I want to learn
more about these babies but I can't
without basically asking what tricks
does it do I mean that is kind of the
thing that you do you you are basically
asking what new tricks does your human
pet do can it okay like does it have
does it have a weird bone coming out of
its mouth can it roll over like things
that basically any human can do but it's
very weird when a baby does it for the
first time because a parent has been
living with this strange being in their
house that can do nothing when it starts
nothing it is capable of zero it's just
a point a guy put it down and it stays
there - all the way to like first grade
when it's like you know having
conversations with you well also Hank it
doesn't even stop there humans continue
to do new tricks even after they turn
six yeah I guess so
what Stephanie's question really makes
me think is that essentially all we're
ever asking each other
aside from how's the weather is what new
tricks can you do like whenever I talk
to anyone about anything essentially
what I'm telling them is like there's a
new thing that my body is
doing or there is a new thing that I'm
up to or there is a new thing that's
happening to me it's like then I've got
a new trick my new trick is my back
hurts a lot ya know there has been a
fascinating development it's called the
flu yeah oh man that sucks John I'm
sorry oh I've getting over the flu is
just miserable but it reminds me of the
absolute importance of getting your flu
shot which I did get I just still got
the flu and which is a thing that
happens yes but it increases herd
immunity and it's not really about
saving my life it's about saving the
lives of vulnerable people who are
extremely susceptible to serious
complications from the flu so get your
flu shot
I'm sorry was that the question all of
life is asking people what new tricks
they do Stephanie and so just ask people
what new tricks their babies their
babies are doing and you'll be great
I thought I would never have been able
to put my finger on it John but that is
basically what you're doing and like
it's very difficult to know I had a baby
two years ago I have no idea when they
get teeth I've completely forgotten when
they start talking I've completely
forgotten when they start eating solid
food like when's your first chicken
nuggets I don't know I don't know when
or not his first chicken nugget at a
point and we were probably like we
shouldn't be doing this but like he he
likes it so he's a person he can eat him
person food now
the moment when we could start feeding
or enlike whatever we were having for
dinner was just such a freeing wonderful
moment to be like to go from being cook
I have to feed a separate feeding for
this person and us so we're making two
different dinners to being like oh
whatever we're eating I'll just put it
on his plate really my children are
significantly older than Orin and they
require their own dinners because I
don't like to eat chicken nuggets I mean
Orin eats whatever
hila he eats all food Mike my kids what
my kids do not like Thai food like they
do not like curries orin orin likes
spicy food
he likes he'd had asparagus and ravioli
for dinner last night okay new new new
bed is there any way that you and I can
bet the name of this podcast on whether
Orin is going to like spicy foods and
despairity might like asparagus
whether or unlikely foods and eat all of
the dinners that you eat when Oren is
five oh yeah no I will not take that bet
absolutely not that's going away
it one of the new tricks that your kid
will do in the future is absolutely 100%
refuse to eat curry which reminds me
that we have other questions to answer
so we should probably get to them this
one comes from Kalyan who asks dear Hank
and John I am currently a sophomore in
college double majoring in legal studies
and English I'm hoping to go to law
school after undergrad and I just found
out that space lawyers are real should
or shouldn't I become a space lawyer
pumpkins and penguins Kaelyn I mean no
one told me about this oh you don't know
about space lawyers you know what I mean
I guess there's like there's got to be
somebody doing the law about space
exactly there's a lot of law to figure
out up there what belongs to whom what
spaces can you occupy what where can you
put your satellites I think being a
space lawyer would be cool I actually
have some experience in this field Hank
because your your space law I am NOT a
space lawyer it's gonna surprise you I
haven't been like hiding my law degree
from you for the last 15 years okay I
have however signed a contract that
invoked and involved outer space is the
the Hulu thing cuz no no but I dined a
movie deal okay years ago uh-huh and
when I sign that movie deal one of the
clauses was about how no matter where
the movie or TV show that was made from
my book appeared anywhere on earth at
any time in any medium and also
elsewhere on other planets or anywhere
in the universe this company was gonna
own the rights to that movie and I
remember seeing it and just being like
did you actually are you actually
worried about Mars theaters which other
thing that I like most about that is if
they hadn't thought of that
if they hadn't realized that space
theaters were a problem
people would totally build space
theaters just so that they could show
pirated movies no no exactly this whole
thing occurred because precisely because
lawyers failed to see the internet and
digital distribution covering and all of
these movies were in a weird
land where nobody knew for sure who
owned the rights to what and they had to
go back and pay people again and
everything so they had to be as as
inclusive as possible and so I I think
it literally included the phrase the
known universe but like if you could
show the movie in a different universe
right what about parallel universes like
guy can I leave this timeline please God
just let me leave it can I leave this
timeline go into a different timeline
rewrite the movie and resell the rights
or is that it
yeah there you go
well I mean like honestly maybe maybe
like the fact that they did all this
space lawyering on this contract is
gonna shut down space exploration
because if we had this extra reason to
go to Mars so that we would have like a
whole new way of controlling
intellectual property and we could start
over from scratch they'll be like the
like creative reason to be a Martian
rather than like a scientific or an
extractive industry kind of one where
there'd be like new rules like like
creative anarchy everybody owns
everything again and you can totally
remake Disney movies no problem then
people would go to Mars cuz there'd be a
real strong economic reason to go there
but they shut it down Jon they shut it
down you think you've seen snow white no
no no no wait to see Martian snow white
yeah exactly
I do not think for the record that is a
reason that would truly instead of on
his interstellar we'll never know now
will we Hank I hate to disagree with you
about this but I think the space lawyers
have done us all a service by saying
there will be no new snow white on Mars
you're stuck with the same dang snow
white no matter where you go I
thank you to all the space lawyers out
there for making sure that the
intellectual property rights of
America's largest corporations are
protected under all circumstances I mean
you're making space lowering sound not
great for Kaelin I bet there's a bunch
of other great space law that doesn't
have to do with protecting the rights of
Disney also I mean Disney's a person it
needs its rights protected just like
anybody that's right
that's right John absolutely Disney is a
person and needs its rights protected
just like anybody here we are vote all
right let's answer this question from
Jessica who writes dear John and Hank a
guy I know was hired at the company I
work at and after a couple weeks I
decided to sell my car and he expressed
an interest in it he asked me to
test-drive the car for a week and I let
him so the end of the week came and I
was too shy and non-confrontational to
ask him about it hahaha here's where the
problem becomes worse it's been almost 2
years and he's still using did I let him
steal my car is it his car now is not a
way to do anything about it should I
find an opportunity to blow up the car
and keep the insurance money you got
your ideas Jessica that is the worst
idea I yeah well I mean except for maybe
letting him continue to drive the car in
which like you own the vehicle and are
thus liable for like what he's doing
with it
yeah exactly that is the big concern
here Jessica aside from everything else
like I suspect the person who's done
this is is pretty manipulative and has
kind of put you in a situation where
every time you've tried to bring it up
they make it seem like why are you
trying to bring up that thing we're cool
if it's a company if it's just that
truly you you just never wanted to bring
it up then you need to work on the
confrontation skills I guess I can kind
of see how this happens because I am
also pretty non confrontational but it's
one of those situations where the risk
that you are taking on by continuing to
let this person drive your car because
it is still your car like it's still
under your name
everything and and also you're paying
insurance every month the Rob ibly the
risk is too high so you have to go I
know it's gonna suck but you have to go
and you have to say hey you know the car
that you've been driving for two years
that's my car I need my car back and I
need it back to today yeah
and just say you know what you can say
Jessica actually just set him to the pod
we're gonna do it right now hey
congratulations on having driven a car
for two years that was not your car and
it's been a good run and that's great
and I'm very happy for you but now it's
time to drive a car that you do own
because Jessica needs her car back that
was a really weird thing to do man it
was a little weird man I mean I you know
I think I is a little weird Jessica I
think it's probably easy to blame
yourself for this situation and and yeah
I think that you like clearly there
should have been moments where you were
more assertive in this but ultimately
like that is also on this person it's
time you got to get your car back you
got to get your car back I'm glad that
we can help I don't know that we are you
kidding Hank we've never helped this
next question comes from Lange who
writes Dear John and Hank I have a
question that has plagued me lo these
many years of my bathroom using life if
I'm in a bathroom stall and someone in a
different stall sneezes should I say
bless you oh no yeah you don't have to
be polite like that you can say whatever
you want you could be like oh that was a
good one buddy nope no no God instead of
saying bless you you just like you
compliment the sneeze or you like good
you go bigger is the thing that you wow
that's the worst advice that's ever been
given on our podcast which is really
saying anywhere yeah no it's a cone of
silence clang like no matter what no
matter where if you are in the stall
next to the person who is really doing
anything it's a cone of silence because
we all have to create in our minds a
world of privacy that does not actually
exist and when that world of privacy is
interrupted such as when I was in a
urinal recently and I was peeing and
they were
I was inside of it yeah no I was in yeah
it was weird man this big urinal I was
at sorry I'm not very good with
prepositions I was at a urinal recently
and the person who is peeing next to me
said are you the author of The Fault in
Our Stars and I was like it's it's
ruined it's it's this is this is you've
ruined peeing for me forever I'm never
gonna be able to do it again and I hope
they don't listen to the pod because I
don't I don't want to call them out or
anything but I was of course extremely
awkward in my answer because I was I was
having a moment in the in the cone of
silence I was inside a world where I my
belief system has always been that when
you are in the bathroom when you are not
alone you pretend that you are alone and
you are as respectful of everyone else's
privacy as you can be I have had a
number of conversations and while the
bathroom things are occurring and I've
never been a huge fan of them myself I
try to let people be who they are I did
have a guy who come up to the urinal
next to me at a Chili's one time and say
let's see if this old thing still works
and I appreciate that like long-term it
was a good story at least was he
referring to the urinal nope
oh yeah I get it it's a yes it's a joke
about genitalia that's good it's good I
haven't heard one of those before I
wonder if that's gonna catch on yeah
uh-huh yeah yeah like I you know I was
in high school and he was uh you know
he'd been he'd been around for a while
and I did get to go back to my table and
tell everybody that story so I don't
mind give my story to tell I have to say
I love it when old people have standard
lines yeah god I have an affection for
old people's standard lines no matter
what they are and I'm I'm entering the
age where I realized that I am an old
person with standard lines like my best
friend Chris whenever he is this is so
dumb but I I find it so charming
whenever we're at a restaurant if
somebody asks if he wants a refill of
his diet
coke he always says no thanks I have to
drive that's really that's really bad I
love it though like I just realized how
bad of a line that is but every single
time he says that I'm like oh god it's
cuz you know he's not drinking alcohol
but he's making it's funny it's funny
you know it's like that coke really
effects them go straight to his head
the caffeine but yeah so I don't I never
begrudge an old person their standard
lines unless those standard lines are
like you know deeply offensive or
whatever so I don't know for me that's
that's a little bit in the in-between
space but in general I think you try to
preserve other people's privacy when
you're in the restroom with them yeah
I've definitely had people coming to the
bathroom and recognized me and then like
do the double take and then be like nope
nope this is not the place and I'm like
correct we are all we are all equal in
the tiled safe clean stinky place all
right John here's another question it's
from Abigail who asks dear Hank and John
hello I'm a high school senior who's
just had her first college admissions
interview oh I'm sorry
oh my gosh that sounds stressful I was
extremely nervous and studied everything
about the school beforehand I rehearsed
all my answers to questions like what
inspires you and which extracurricular
activity is your favorite however I was
in no way prepared for the first
question my interviewer asked tell me a
little bit about yourself how am I
supposed to respond to this is this a
prompt to go into my whole life story in
my deep struggles or is it a time to
tell her like what my Panero order is
[Laughter]
like until you ask this question it had
never occurred to me how weird it is to
ask someone to tell you a bit about
themselves because really like the first
thing I want to say is okay so get this
I have a consciousness and that I'm able
to think thoughts that are separate from
the world but I am inside of a body
okay okay College Admissions interviewer
get this I came out of another person
and so did you or you could be like
sometimes when I'm by myself I like
stare into the middle distance and I
think like my head is completely empty
of thought right now and then I think
like wait was that a thought like it's a
bit like they just want to know a bit so
that's a good bit you could also be like
oh my like a second toe is is longer
than my big toe yeah you want to know
like just a little bit about me yeah I
have brown eyes
would you like you to go on you tell me
when we've had enough bits yeah you tell
me when you have enough it's like the
pepper on the Caesar salad whatever it
is Abigail the thing you gotta do is go
all in on it
that's terrible advice do not go all in
on it if you can't be like everybody
else and be like well here the sports I
like no you got to be like here is
everything that you ever wanted to know
about my toes know what that is I mean
yeah that don't do that Abigail what
they want you to say is what you're
passionate about what you're interested
in what well when you think about
yourself what makes you different from
other people applying to that College
ultimately like this person talks to a
lot of people and so probably not much
but maybe going a little deeper and
being like I mean a little bit about
myself like I am amazed by like this big
the human story like have you ever
thought about how everyone of us comes
out of a person don't do that do not do
that no no because you don't you don't
want to go you don't want to go that
hard you just you need this is the very
beginning of the interview if you
haven't got swing for the fences go
Hawks
no don't swing for the fences try to hit
a double this is not a situation to be
like well I'm
either strike out or we're all going
home cuz I'm into this College in minute
for no the other thing they're trying to
establish is that you're going to be
able to interact with and contribute to
the university community in a productive
way so being like here's everything you
need to know about my second toe is I
would argue not know as grey forward
yeah you definitely you also definitely
don't want to talk for too long that's
probably a red flag for this person tell
me a little bit about yourself and then
like thirty minutes later they're like
uh-huh I'll just put a checkmark in this
box that was worth everyone's time I
guess I remember when the college
interviewer at Kenyon asked me to tell
them what book I loved for some reason I
answered zen and the art of motorcycle
may which is a which is I have no idea
if it's a good book because the relevant
the relevant fact about that book in
that moment is that at the time I said
those words I had read perhaps fifty
pages of it and I went on to maybe read
like twelve more so it asked to name a
book that like identified and embodied
my value system I named a book that I
had not read if I had a college
admissions interview I do not remember
it that's the only thing I remember
because immediately they were like and
and what is it about that that you
responded to so deeply and I was like
and what is it about that that I
responded to so deeply hmm can I can i
reenter the question can we go back
Soula by Toni Morrison or another book
that I have finished can I get to
actually talk about any of a number of
very good books I've actually read look
I want to be the kind of person who was
deeply affected by zen and the art of
motorcycle maintenance that doesn't mean
that i am that person but i want to be
that person and so i'm going to go with
that i'm not even sure that i do want to
be that person but i think i want to be
that person based on the title and the
fifty page
that I read in the car on the way up
here rides me John that this podcast is
brought to you by books we haven't read
but want people to think that we are the
kind of person who likes today's vodkas
also brought to you of course by
Jessica's car Jessica's car wasn't soon
to be Jessica's again and this podcast
this October also brought to you by
John's giant urinal he's in there and
lastly today's podcast is brought to you
by the Martian snow white if you haven't
seen the Mars snow white you don't know
the real story ooh
the real story now I'm worried that
that's gonna encourage people to go to
Mars which would be so bad for me nobody
ever thinks about in all the
conversations I see about sending humans
to Mars nobody ever talks about the the
John Green implications yeah it's like
they think that I'm tangential to the
whole human story John this next
question comes from Hannah who asks dear
Hank and John I was at my local Wawa the
other day that's like a convenient story
I know wah wah okay and I ordered a cup
of soup I was gonna get a drink to go
along with my soup but then I started
thinking what do you drink with soup
soup is already liquidy it seems weird
to drink something with it but I feel
like in the past I've had soup lots of
times and never had a problem deciding
what to drink with it just another
palindrome Hannah this is weird because
I have this experience too if I think
about it I have a hard time drinking
while I'm eating soup but if I don't it
doesn't seem to affect me maybe I'm not
drinking maybe I'm just having soup and
like I don't have to drink can you just
have your drink in your food yeah yeah
in fact we get a lot of our water our
daily water from our food not from
drinking water that sounds like a
suspiciously like a science fact John
well it's true I I only know that
because I one of the areas of my
obsessive interest for a while
was um how much water I needed to drink
and of what kind in order to prevent
being I we don't need to get into it I
know a lot about how much water you're
supposed to drink because just I don't
know
I get interested in stuff here's the
point when you're drinking hot soup you
want to drink ice-cold
liquid it's just a wonderful go back and
forth yeah it was like a nice ice-cold
Diet Dr Pepper it's just perfect for a
chicken noodle soup I was with you there
for a second oh you don't want to do is
you don't wanna have like hot chicken
noodle soup and then hot coffee because
then you're just like oh this coffee is
terrible soup Iowa I will often have hot
soup with tea because like if I might
get a Vietnamese place they give you tea
and they give you hot soup and I'm like
I like I shouldn't have the tea before
the soup showed up because this is too
much but I I think that it's hot soup in
ice water like that's the way to do it
because you got like a salt and I don't
like to switch back and forth between
like a coke and a soup that doesn't feel
right to me that it does feel right to
me the switch back and forth between
chips in a coke which is why that's so
devious of a combination of foods I can
do that forever I love chips and coke
alright I think this next question comes
from Kieran who writes Dear John and
Hank I recently read an absolutely
remarkable thing and I loved it however
I was wondering if it would be okay to
give it to my literature teacher who I
don't know very well I'm concerned that
it might be weird for an eighth grade
student to give a teacher a book with
some not school friendly content in it
on the other hand it's a great book and
I want her to read it if I do give it to
her do I tell her that it has
questionable content or do I not say
anything and let her wonder what kind of
person I am
I mean Kieran I don't know what book you
read but I don't think that it has
questionable content it has some bad
words in it some some obscenity but I
don't think it has anything in it that
your literature teacher would be like
hold on there that's not the Kieran that
I was expecting yeah I mean you know we
can kind of feel that way about like the
parts of language and of behavior that
are considered in a moral way like I
think that I don't think of much
language certainly some language I
consider in a moral way where like when
I hear people using that language I
think they are doing something that is
morally questionable I don't feel that
way about like the f-word but I do feel
that way about other words so like I can
see how
you would feel that and and in different
parts of the world different parts the
country that is a that is a more sort of
common perspective and I understand that
in like understood it as I was writing
the book and knew that it would be to
some people it would be kind of a
barrier to it but I hope that that's not
the case for your literature teacher and
I'm honored that you would consider
sharing the book and and I really hope
that you do because I I hope that I hope
that more people find it and I really
especially hope that that teachers will
like it and share it with their classes
yeah yeah it's such a big deal for
students to share books they love with
teachers because it helps teachers
discover new books I can't tell you how
many teachers have told me that they
first read Looking for Alaska or The
Fault in Our Stars or whatever because
one of their students gave it to them
and I also think it shows a lot of
respect for your teacher to say I like
the books that we're reading I respect
you as a teacher and I want to share a
book that I love with you now they may
be busy and they may not have time to
read it but I think it's still nice to
do Hank speaking of your brand-new book
and absolutely remarkable thing we have
another question from Seema who writes
dear John a Nick I have problems taking
money whenever I do a job for someone
such as babysitting when the money in
collecting time comes around I just get
so awkward
I understand I did a service for them
and I deserve to be paid but I still
can't shake the weird feeling that I'm
taking something from them when they pay
me so then I make it more awkward by
trying to make it less awkward I sort of
act surprised when they're paying me
like oh thank you and then I leave it's
so annoying and I get mad at myself when
I do that what can I do to make myself
feel better about taking other people's
money
who's got the keys to my Bheema Seema Oh
Seema I think I mispronounced your name
at the beginning but thank you for that
very helpful rhyme I have this problem
too and I had to work so hard in my life
to become the expert at self-promotion
that I've become I don't know if you've
read my new book turtles all the way
down but it got great reviews it is
really hard because we're taught by the
social order that accepting payment for
work
is in some ways like embarrassing or
naughty yeah well I don't know John I
kind of feel like it's the opposite that
like it is more natural for us to plike
do favors for each other and to sort of
have a like a sort of like a small group
understanding of I do this for you you
do this for me and like this is in like
economies are relatively new you know
cultural constructions they're a
technology and so figuring out how to
like incorporate that technology into
you and be like okay this is how I
understand the world I think that's not
natural I think it takes work and it
takes learning and yeah that I feel
that's how I feel and I think that it
like it's a skill that must be learned I
love the idea of a 16 year old
babysitting for you and then you come
back after a nice for our date with your
spouse and you say hey Seema thanks so
much for babysitting
as I'm sure you know economies are a
very new technology and this whole like
money exchange thing is not natural or
normals and so what I'm gonna do Seema
is I'm not gonna pay you for your work
today but what I am gonna do is when you
need a for our favor I'm going to get a
different 16 year old to do that for you
and then I'm just gonna build kind of a
favor Network sort of a bartering
network where I'm at the top it is
essentially what it is Seema is it's a
multi-level marketing scheme I'm on the
top I'm gonna have a I'm gonna have a
million favors from other from teenagers
and I'm gonna catch them all in and you
know what I'm gonna get John this is a
lot of cars washed I know I'm not saying
that the technology of economies is bad
or that like I don't utilize it which
obviously I do it's just that it like it
is something that I feel like you have
to assert yourself into you have to be
you have to to like do the thing even if
it feels uncomfortable and then
eventually
feels comfortable like many of the
things that we do that at first are
really sort of like overwhelming and
feel a little bit you know a little bit
wrong a little bit unnatural like
something is simple it's like calling a
stranger on the phone like it feels
weird it's not it doesn't feel natural
because like obviously it's not phones
aren't our pretty new thing talking to
strangers is a pretty new thing yeah
talking to strangers is a pretty new
thing and I never thought about that
let's go back to when it was verboten
can we move back to what we never talk
to strangers that'd be great
whereas I'm like that was a nice sneeze
there next time I hope you're having a
pleasant afternoon house you poo let's
see if this old thing still works we got
to answer one more question before we
get to the all-important news from Mars
and AFC Wimbledon this question comes
from Asia who asks dear Hank and John
nope
Dear John and Hank dang it I caught
myself my boyfriend is 25 and works in
an escape room he got this job after he
graduated with a degree in biology he's
worked there for almost two years and at
this point his family is starting to
pressure him to get a quote real job the
problem is he loves his job at the job
he has learned how to build puzzles and
code along with minor electrical and
construction skills this isn't something
he thought he'd do or love so much but
his resolve is fading and he's starting
to talk about leaving this job for a job
that he'll hate he says you only get to
like your job for so long ah I don't
think that's true and even talking about
quitting makes him so sad how do I
encourage him to stay in a job he loves
should I not I know this isn't what most
people would consider a real job and has
nothing to do with his degree but isn't
loving your job important thanks in
advance
I trust your guidance Asia that's a
terrible mistake I think because this is
a new job like it's a thing that hasn't
existed for a while it's not that it's
not biology it's not that it's not that
it's that it's something that people
haven't heard of that much and so maybe
if he can frame it differently in his
mind that will help because ultimately
like there are lots of like
really legitimate jobs that probably
nobody in his life would be like oh
you've got a degree in biology but now
you like work at City Hall like no one
would think that it also may be a lower
paying job at least for now but and I
completely agree with you Hank if you're
still being pushed and you're still
learning things you're learning about
how to code and how to build puzzles and
learning electrical skills while you're
getting paid like that's great
especially if you're interested in that
stuff and passionate about it because
you don't know where that can lead and
so if you still feel fulfilled by the
work let it grow I I agree like I don't
know if escape rooms are going to end up
being like a growth industry but I do
think that being able to code and being
able to understand puzzles is going to
be a big growth industry in the future
yeah it sounds like his job is like
problem solving which is it in the end
everybody's job to some extent but but
like really directly applied and the the
only thing that I would say if your if
your boyfriend is listening to this
podcast right now which hopefully he is
is maybe also try to get involved in the
business of the escape room and you know
let your colleagues know that that's
something that you are also interested
in because then you are not like an
escape room designer you are also a
business manager and management skills
can be spread across lots of different
jobs including jobs in biology yeah if
you're operationally strong and you
understand the basics of business and
you can get things done you can get a
lot of different jobs and I think that
it sounds like you're on a great path
actually yeah
I think it's great Congrats on the cool
job alright think before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon I got a to share with you a
couple things first off we got a letter
from Marika who wrote in to say that she
lives in Berlin and the amusement park
in Berlin I talked about with the
abandoned ferris wheel is actually being
reopened they are they are making it
into a new amusement park and they're
going to save the ferris wheel
apparently oh my gosh yeah also all seas
are going to be powered by the wind
still are they going to
with like electricity I think they're
gonna go with electricity for this one
but I'm not totally sure also we
received several really helpful and
interesting emails from autistic
listeners on the question of eye contact
I wanted to read this one from Claire
who writes hi uh green boys in regards
to the episode of the pod where you
talked about where to look when talking
to someone I'm autistic so eye contact
is extremely difficult for me but over
time I've come up with some tricks that
I use when talking to people that may be
helpful when I'm in a situation where I
probably should be making eye contact
such as an interview I stare at a
feature near the person's eyes but not
at their eyes directly such as their
glasses if they wear them their eyebrows
their nose or their eye makeup if they
have any on it gives the illusion that
you're looking at their eyes without the
terror of actually doing so I hope this
helps and I hope I'm allowed to name
specific sign off even though I'm not
asking a question we scare because we
care
oh we scare because we Claire I also
really wanted to share this tip from
Maggie who says dear Hank and John I am
currently sitting at a bus stop where a
bus just pulled up to see if I wanted to
get on I did not want to get on so the
driver opened the door and told me the
correct protocol for signaling this to
an oncoming bus is according to the
driver wave your hand horizontally at
your neck in a kind of salute slash
throat cutting gesture so you know this
one that like Jonah Hill does in the
jiff that you've seen oh yeah I know
that gif now it's it's pronounced either
way the thing that I thought Maggie was
saying at first was like sliding your
finger across your neck which you
shouldn't do that to a bus driver that's
very different from the waving fan at
your throat this is like no no no not me
this other one is like I'm going to kill
you bus driver right yeah no just Google
Jonah Hill gif or possibly gif nobody
knows for sure yeah it's the first one
that came up of course it is I mean
Jonah Hill has done a lot of work in his
career but that jiff is by far the most
important thing he's done Oh God Jonah
Hill seems like a great
you know it's not great that's that's my
idea of a transition well that's not
great John well Hank it's time to put
the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon I
don't know if the news from Mars is good
but the news from AFC Wimbledon is
terrible AFC Wimbledon have lost their
third straight game to nil and their
fifth sixth sixth straight game overall
it's a very difficult period our CEO
Eric Samuelson who works tirelessly for
the club for the salary of exactly one
pound per year posted a very kind
thoughtful considered note to the fans
talking about where do we go from here
there's a lot of talk about potentially
firing the manager Neal Ardley who is a
Wimbledon youth player played for the
first team just cares so much about
Wimbledon there's no question about that
but you know at what point do you try to
figure out a different path forward to
try to stay up it's not clear but Eric
pointed out in the letter that clubs who
fire their manager midseason do not
often see an improvement in results now
and so it's just a really hard thing I
mean one of the reasons that this is
such a difficult season is you know if
you go back and listen to early episodes
of the pod where I'm talking about
Wimbledon in the fourth tier of English
football I say over and over again that
they have the smallest stadium they have
one of the smallest playing budgets and
yet they somehow found a way to get
promoted well you know in the third tier
of English football it's it's only going
to be harder and so these are big
problems I do not have a solution for
them I don't think anyone does it's just
a really hard time so right now
Wimbledon are second to last in the
league one table have to find a way to
finish 20th this year to stay up if
we've somehow managed to do that that
means that we can make it to next year
and during the season next year
hopefully the new stadium will open and
Wimbledon will be
on the up-and-up again but it's just
gonna be a hard year there's no two ways
about it all right John the news from
Mars if you want an opportunity Rover
update basically NASA is gonna keep
listening until January but it has been
for months now so not great but
additionally to that so in order to get
the Mars 2020 Rover to the surface of
Mars a number of things have to go right
one of those things is you know they're
gonna shoot this thing at Mars very very
fast
so that it gets there relatively quickly
and then it slows down by hitting Mars
front of Mars then it hits first is of
course the atmosphere so Mars has a
pretty thin atmosphere but it is enough
of an atmosphere that it can slow down
especially because the thing isn't going
to go straight at Mars it's going to go
sort of parallel so that it's been a lot
more time in the atmosphere that slows
it down but then it will release its
parachute and they have been testing the
parachute that will get the Mars 2020
Rover onto the surface of Mars a bunch
just did the final test and it opened
perfectly great and the thing about this
is so so one you have to figure out how
to simulate the atmosphere of Mars so in
order to do that you have to have the
the parachute open on Earth's atmosphere
which is much thicker except when you're
at a high altitude so they shoot this
thing way up in the air they get it
going very fast and then they open it at
a specific speed at a specific altitude
which is the speed that it will be going
and the and the pressure of the Mars
atmosphere which is basically perfect we
can actually simulate this really
accurately and then they have different
loads that is on the end of the
parachute to make sure that the
parachute doesn't rip or rupture which
their early experiments when they were
first starting to do this did a lot
because the parachute opens in around of
I think four tenths of a second so it's
a very it's about the size of a house so
it goes from the size of like a like a
log of wood to like that you would throw
on a fire
to the size of a house you know fourth
of a second so that's a lot of pressure
and it is a sudden and tremendous amount
of weight that is yanking on all of
these nylon fibers and all of the
stitching and all of the fabric so the
the parachute opened perfectly at
supersonic speeds with a load of 67,000
pounds to the heaviest ever payload for
a parachute ever any parachute and 85%
heavier than the payload that Mars 2020
parachute will have to slow during its
descent toward Mars so you know as they
do at NASA this is planned to succeed
way beyond where it will have to succeed
and it is succeeded quite well so that's
great news for Mars 2020 the parachute
is functional the rover body is getting
painted right now the chassis is is
complete and they're gahbage the holes
drilled in it and all the instruments
are still under your construction for
the most part and but will be being
finished up soon and shipped over to
start being assembled into the final
rover it's just amazing didn't the first
Mars rover didn't curiosity not use a
parachute or did it use a parachute it
used a parachute so it's a combination
of multiple slowing mmm shooters and
there's the like there's the Rockets
that fire toward the surface of Mars
yeah I mean technically the first
slowdown is just the capsule hitting the
atmosphere and so that slows it down a
lot and then the parachute opens to slow
it down even further because if the
parachute opened at like at the like
when it first hit the atmosphere the
parachute would totally rip off because
it'd be going too fast
so it slows down a lot just by going
through the atmosphere then the
parachute opens then it drops the
parachute and it gets lowered by this
ridiculous sky crane thing placed
carefully on the surface of Mars which
is I can't frickin believe it worked
even now wait a sky crane will land on
Mars first and then lower the rover down
no the sky crane is is a crane that is
suspended in the sky by retro rockets so
it oh wow yeah that is cool
yeah it's pretty cool it just completely
boggles my mind how much engineering
brilliance goes into this like they just
there was just a problem on the
International Space Station where there
was this like pinprick sized hole mm-hmm
and they had to patch it or whatever I
don't really remember the details what I
remember is they were like what probably
cause this is human error when doing the
stitching and I was like oh right all of
this stuff that is going into space is
made by people somehow I had not
internalized that yeah yeah it's pretty
amazing like when they're talking about
building the chassis for Mars 2020
they're talking about like drilling the
holes that the instruments will connect
to and they drill each one by hand right
and they so they do a pilot hole and
then they do a second pilot hole to make
sure that they're in the exact right
spot and then they do the final drill
because like every hole of course needs
to be like perfectly in exactly the
right spot but it's done by a person
there's yeah person with a drill yeah
like we are not a species of artificial
intelligence or whatever we are a
biological phenomenon like turning cloth
and metal into space stations yeah
anyway that's what you should tell your
interviewer when they ask you to tell
them a bit about you and every one of
those people came out of a person it's
humans all the way down Hank thank you
for ponding with me thanks to everybody
for listening we're gonna go now and
make our patreon podcast at patreon.com
slash dear Hank and John it's called
this weekend Ryan's and it is terrible
it's bad this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins so is so is this week
in Ryan's it's produced by rosianna
halse rojas and shared and Gibson our
head of community and communications is
Victoria bon giorno the music that
you're hearing now and at the beginning
of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]